okay so we what do we do we mentally
schedule meetings what examines that
mean so this is on the left side of pain
column is how you're typically scheduled
a meeting let's say at the end of this
is Chad you send an email say Alex let's
not be sometime next week and I just if
I have an assistant
I would CC you know Amy and say hey just
call Amy Amy and and then kind of
typically what happens with the personal
assistant is that that the assistant
will take over that conversation stop
sending use some email saying hey Alice
it's actually free next week is
available for coffee next weekend you
know 2 p.m. on Tuesday and so on so
that's the that's what we do and the
question is then how has we do that and
so we think about it we need this really
for different areas of APRI different
technology area that we are attacking
first we need to understand the email
that you sent in to us to have this be
able to have that conversation with you
right so natural language processing and
that national natural language
understanding is a big piece of what we
think a piece of our product which part
of what we talk we'll talk about today
in terms of the architect is empowering
that but the second piece is actually
the conversation
how do we be able to actually have a
conversation with you because when you
email us we have to have to email back
which is very different than some of the
other system out there that you used
before that needs more of a Curie based
system for us it's more of a
conversation based system so now
thinking about the before talking about
the the database choices or data
architecture or how we model data and so
on I just wanted given that the product
I want a little bit more about these so
what does that mean it has a
characteristic and then after that talk
about the technical choices that we made
so we need quick response time so I make
the distinction between that in real
time because I I come from real time
world where my last venture is in real
time analytics and velocity of real time
there is a separate meaning to this for
us in in X today I dealing with emails
is you want to respond quickly but
losing five seconds in the processing
for example it's not a big deal right so
we want quick responses but we actually
have some luxury in not having to do
self 100 milliseconds response and so
and so forth another thing about is that
we apply a lot of machine learning and
we need a lot of data from machine
learning and so being able to have it
back end as support this large kind of
back end machine learning is important
to us again compared to our last
ventures which is a in a real time
perspective where you're more of on a
stream processing here is more about
offline training right something that we
can train the model again we have the
luxury of time in in processing and
building the model and that so that it
can support the real-time or the the
quick responses that we need in in in
sort of production environment in terms
of scaling so you know we we certainly
sign up customers to use our service and
and you know every customer schedules
XML and and numbers meetings um so as
more more users we add we linearly scale
up the number of meetings which you know
it that's the the key metrics that we we
we follow and for every person you meet
with X number of people right so you
know as I scheduled coffee with you and
you and so on and then so it is this um
this idea of a graph that Satya merge if
you think about it and then there are
different data sets that are being
shared right so you know all of us are
showing up a Spotify today that some of
you might have if your favorite coffee
shop to be Grumpy's you know we might
have who worked at the same company and
so on so forth so when we model this the
data that we had to take that into
account of that we have a unique users
who are in different in varying various
meetings who are with other people but
my Maya might not share some of these
other attributes or entities so with
that what what are the challenges then
being able to build a conversation robot
in compared to some of the other
national language on machine learning
technique is that our challenge is being
able to achieve a extremely high
accuracy because we the last thing we
want is that experience that you have
happen you might have which say Siri
they say you know what night she doesn't
understand what I'm saying we want that
experience back to our my second slide
magical we want that conversation to be
so natural we want the conversation to
that is our interface if we don't have
an app we don't have a website I mean we
have a lot of marketing website but um
do you interact with with us with just
CC and AMI
to the product so being able to have
that national conversation with you
being able to understand what you said
before understand context and on the
conversation that we are having with you
is super important to us and that
requires a different set of focus in the
in the technology um yeah second piece
of the is idea of having a conversation
so for example I say if I just email you
and say hey I'm free next Tuesday at
5:00 p.m. and then and Thursday at 2:00
p.m. and you just email me Beyonce sure
2 p.m. works what I said if I just
analyze at 2:00 p.m. what does that mean
like without context
I couldn't narrow it down to what you
actually meant Tuesday at 2:00 p.m. so
being able to carry that context which
again this is it's a bit different than
say if you do in Google query they just
say you know who's Abraham Lincoln and
then if you say next query is like when
it's his birthday Google wouldn't tell
you when because it will lost contacts
in the in the bring the process I'm sure
a little bit more about kind of the data
structure but yes certainly there is a
bunch of different relationship between
different entities in our system which
we have to take that into account as we
pick our database and and model our data
I think it's pretty natural or pretty
common for natural language processing
and machine learning that deal with a
lot of sparse data so for example if
you're working with a lot of texts you
know we keying on let's say Engram as a
feature that we picking out specific
words that that appeared out of the many
millions a combination that you can have
on a furry gram for example so being
able to take that into account and then
we want to change fast we want to be
able to make changes we are set up after
all we don't being around it's in 8
April 2014
so being able to pick technologies and
data models that is flexible enough to
allow us to to add feature to to iterate
and then super important to us
so if it's that stack everything sold on
Amazon we do use quite a few of the
Amazon services including sqs they'll be
and so on and so forth
I will tell you more about the database
a back-end and data science all done in
Scala we do have a back deponent we
don't have any apps but we do have some
internal web apps and on the website
that are powered by your node and
angular so with the technical challenge
that we just mentioned earlier we are
not processing insane amount of data
because partially because of people to
have to actually email us right so the
number it is the number of emails that
we care about in a part of it in a
scaling perspective that but we care
about every single email we do a lot of
things to every single email we do tons
of processing so in a way that's D the
challenge of being able to make sure
that we don't lose any data and then we
are processing all the data again coming
back from where my prior adventure where
we are doing big data analytics in which
we're doing counting a lot of data to do
the kind of page views and aggregating
pages and so on but if you lost a page
view it's actually not the end of the
world here we cannot lose a single email
it is super important that we both not
lose any process so with that we put in
the queue based architecture so you know
when email comes into what we call a
receiver which really is a receive the
email and it threads into certain email
conversation threads and then quickly
put it into a sqs queue after that we
have our seed annotator so this is a
quick version of our and an LP pipeline
in the beginning on a very very high
level but the annotators not extract so
that the entities that we care about so
for meeting if you think about it is we
really care for three entries we to
think about we care about who shouldn't
be
what time and where so those are the
three sets and the diva particularly
interested in and then be able to
classify the email itself into
susceptible context understanding of
what are you trying to say to us
so when you say 2:00 p.m. works versus
2:00 p.m. doesn't work we need to
understand that right even though
there's the same time entity we pick SQS
SRQ partially is this these abuse we do
like the sort of free scale scalability
that brings to us that did it was really
relatively easy to add into our
infrastructure to to add to give us that
safety in a way then you know if we want
to take down the annotated 5 minutes we
could it just sits in it all the email
just sits in the queue and it brings it
back up and again without losing any
data which is very important to us and
there are some challenges sqs for
example the the maximum payload is 256
kilobyte so if you have big messages and
sometimes our emails are quite big we
can't fit it on the payload so I mean we
do have our database our payroll a lot
of stuff for some of these processes we
store the payload in the in our other
database and pass along the just the ID
of the of the message that we need and
then we count the ID so come up with it
Aki's actually in place want to how
we're gonna pick our database when we
first started the company again starting
with some criteria that said that we
care about we want to be familiar with
the technology I mean we love trying new
things but at the same time if we can
find something that we are familiar with
it certainly adds to the speed of
building new things that we want we want
to be innovative innovative in the in
the AI machine learning space not in
database technology per se
so with that you know fitting in the
room with the startup startup
environment we want something that will
have a low initial
we do not have a dedicated Edda kated
DevOps team that that we really don't
have time to to care for the database
that much we need to have understanding
on it and be able to utilize it to its
fullest but but that's the trade-off
right because at the end of the day I
don't think there is a perfect database
I think there is a best choice for your
application for the stage that you are
at and I think that's the evolution of
architecture and database in general so
to us is is how do we match a database
that is important to us for our current
use cases so yeah back to the the
iteration and speed piece we want
something that gives us a flexible
schema because we're not quite sure
we're pretty sure about what the schema
this girl look like
but as this users that user use the
product we start thinking about new use
cases we want to add subtract change how
we how we modify our data storage and
how we model out data and being able to
quickly do that it's just important to
us again finding something that's easily
easy early scaling that we want people
to scale somewhat with the initial
database but I certainly don't need it
to scale all the way to you know
hundreds of millions of users but some
scaling will be will be nice and then
you're having reasonable production
quality right being able to provide that
certain safety that we know we can run a
production system on it but willing to
trade off some of the really deep
production infrastructure with with some
of the low energy or maintenance and
that possibility as we go forward
so we think ma was a choice we again
from up from of high adventure
we ran a mongrel cluster a shot at
mobile cluster before up to processing
15 billion pages a month so we know it's
scales pretty well although to be honest
Adela who is that not work very well so
I think we will if we ever get to that
level we have to i have another
discussion but what do we get for
though it is schema-less that we can we
can store complex dictionary in them as
we need however and we can modify them
on the fly that does have is it because
actually a pros and cons but combining
it with the second point makes it a lot
make like a lot easier having Mongoose
as the add-on which Mongoose give you a
schema control right you can you can
although the database itself doesn't
restrict anything about what you want to
put in we actually in our code define
the schema so that when we do change it
in the code we we actually don't mess up
what's in the database
which is something we got burned before
from of high adventure where when
someone just saw some three services
upstream to decide a caste and then in
such a time into two to a character and
it often you could your apps that
cracking down the room you don't know
why and scrapping this data button from
the database so we won't prevent that
from happening it does pretty when the
warm out of the box
we gave very little maintenance I mean
we do have a lot of working knowledge
with but yeah it really did kind
of work all the box for us so we just
that was very nice and having a rep
represent riff kisses that is actually
quite nice it give us the the safety of
you know if your master database
fail display will take over
automatically again with really little
maintenance that required and we can
keep scaling up there Robo set by upping
ups by scaling up the machines in set up
after you it's charting
which I'll talk about the contact and
then you know what would this provide a
provide the monitoring service we just
and
which is actually a pretty good right
out of the box give you pretty decent
analytic step out to perform on your
performance of your database and alerts
come free with it and then all that nice
it pretty graphs comes to come come free
with it as well and in say early startup
scaling that is actually quite quite
nice so those are all all process showed
us to pick a mango console so being a
schema-less database in we
actually doesn't do joints within the
database so every time we have the joint
data it happens in the application level
you have to pull data do the
manipulation and then I combine data
together it just become a different
pattern that you certainly do with some
performance in that but you know
performant that we want to try it is
aegis painting de but to do backup
yourself
we've done it before and it's it it's
supposed to work pretty well you you you
have additional slave and then you take
that slave offline you do a mambo dumb
and then you get the dumped and then you
put attach the slave back into the rebel
setting should be should just work but
then sometimes it's because of the
voting system or if it just happened
that one of your other node also fail at
the same time when you took off the
other slaves it's just kind of
production nightmare but the the pro
selection on that is that longer does
provide as a service for a backup
service which which we reuse which sorts
saw most of that problem we said I want
to do more backup more frequently I
think they do the backup every six hours
so but at least that's decent for what
we're looking for and there's a safety
and then the last two points is really
when you're running at scale it's
something that we certainly don't want
to do again I think shotting is
not something that's fun and then across
data center
deployment is also not awesome
as well and I think once you get to that
level of scaling a lot of the nice thing
that we got from the beginning the the
low maintenance right out of the box the
lag the all those things kind of go out
the window
awesome you need to support it you need
to really understand what's going on
with and so on so if so when we
get to that point we certainly want to
we think kind of what we want to want to
have in terms of a database oh it's like
one more thing when we were running long
ago we were using manga version 2 6
which is a the difference right now that
manga is manga version 3 which we just
upgraded to but one key feature is
missing which is document level locking
so when you are accessing so we version
2 6 we have to have database level
locking so when you're accessing some
some document in the database they have
lost of whole database until that that
interruption is complete so which
actually drive us into having a lot of
different databases just to work on from
mongos limitation of not having document
of the locking again that having solved
with the newer version of but uh
that was a pain that we dealt with for a
long time and actually made our database
architecture a little more complex that
means that we were like
okay so what did they do based in place
we want to set I want to give you a few
examples on how we model our data and
how we think about it so this is a an
excerpt from our a meeting model right
it's a lot longer so I've just picked
out with you if you feel so you know
right there first line is a host which
is what we think about our user the host
of a beating right and then that host
will be meeting with a set up at this
list of participants and then you know
the meeting has a start date and end
date and every current rules if you
never wore my calendar before
recurrently was like the worst thing
ever it just sits is the the most
complex things you can think about and
how many exception there is on you know
you think that you want to be every
Monday and then awesome then well but
every Monday but next Monday or but the
next month everyone we move forward them
but how do you represent that I just
super painful things to to model
yeah I've been timezone how long's the
meeting durations and location now I
highlighted some of these in blue the
blue the participants and location which
is really a separate entities a link to
to a different database and our talk a
little more about why we did that
so yeah it's a quickly thing about some
of the key entities we have in the in
the system so you know again we do mean
things that's what we do and you know
for for meeting this there's a lot of
people in the meeting could be you and
me could be could be those three
gentleman's over there could be so and
so forth right but then like you know we
also could might be in each other's
meeting right like I could be a host in
one meeting and then I guess in
different meeting I might be participant
in in six different meetings and those
are things we need to keep track of
right but then the people share other
entities like back Betty will talk about
you know places you know we we all work
at Spotify we all work at XIII or you
know we all like to go through this
coffee shop so and so forth that those
are the sort of either 1 to n or n to n
relationship that we have across these
different entities and they're selling
something that we want to take into
account as we model the data so one one
major decision that we made when we when
we model the data was about three in bed
everything or should we is not
referencing to create kind of other
entities and reference them across the
database so the way we make this
decision so actually maybe to give the
cookie example so for the envision for
the embedding version the the host
actually has name a nickname a phone
number
primary and secondary email addresses
and a bunch of other stuff that come
along with a person right a participant
in this meeting and then we for the
referencing part we actually talked that
out into a participant database which
had just abstracted that outside and
there's a we can just reference that in
the
in the holes view so what does that mean
though in so that means if you ever want
to if you want if you do in referencing
if you ever wanted queries I understand
get the full view of the meeting we
actually making Cooper ease right you
actually your query for the actual
meeting and then you have to go in and
say I'll give me this idea of the
participant and then I do another query
to get that data to fill the database
but I got to fill the the data so some
of the things we think about is how we
can the how we doing with the majority
of our queries or the queries related to
this set of data do we want to make
these multiple queries for the filling
or what is what are we trading off on
well the trade is that also that are we
going to access the individuals so for
example for the participant case what do
we ever want to just know this person in
the name and their name and so and so
forth and then do we have other
databases that are referencing the same
entity as well because when you do then
those are the times that you want to
start thinking about referencing you
start to be able to access the sub
document that now itself is a major
document and then you can be without
linking across different database of
different entities which give you much
better scaling of that's in that in that
sense yeah I mean we we have to do
application level join so for the
question is how many of those you want
to do based on again the the subtly the
software its usage for cases if you are
referencing so most pyramids are
everything within our production is a
one way of referencing so that they you
know there's enzyme meeting there's a
participant but then we don't
implication we look we don't look at my
phone for each participant how many
meetings I mean we could do those
queries but we actually end up not
needing it in production so then prevent
us of having to do two-way referencing
the problem to a reference referencing
is that now you actually lose atomic
updates every time if you actually
linking a a link you have to actually
update it in two places
and then you run the recipe well wonder
if they actually fails and then now you
have messed up data here's another
example of how we were iterating and
think about our data model so someone
else is a system so we have someone's
assistant but sometimes and that's you
more often than you think
we I don't have to work with the other
persons that the guess assistant now
they say yeah Amy great go talk to my
assistant have the two assistant help
each other so we're trying to figure out
what is the best way to model this
assistant at first we started off the
simple case you know assistant is it's a
person too so let's just make that less
isn't a person so it has all the other
attribute that that other people would
have named nick name and phone number
and all these other things title
signature is a long list of fields but
one will realize is that people only
give us the assistants name and the
email addresses so like it's just bunch
of empty field it's kind of the not very
optimal way to represent the data and it
just makes things a little more
complicated along the way so after
seeing that more often we decided you
know what let's just for a second try
that doesn't make the assistant an
attribute off the of the person so that
you know like you have an assistant cool
that's fine that's your assistant and
then we just work with that and our
logic start dealing with whenever we
detect that we were working with an
assistant who was not addressing the
assistant and not talk to you and but
it's a little logic that we put together
to work with an assistant that is
socially different than how we work with
a
regular yes the problem of the second
try is that then we start getting run
into cases where when the sister work on
multiple people like crap we don't know
what to do with that and then also the
assistant want to schedule their own
meetings too so now the assistant is a
person but also an attribute in someone
else's someone someone else's document
as it's becoming a mess so each week we
come to a third try
where assistant is a separate entity but
actually we just abstracted all the
small just only the necessary stuff
first and last name primary email so
that we can actually cross link link the
assistant to multiple people and then
the individuals and we can query them at
curry against them if we want to but
there's only a bunch of iteration and
then seeing real-life cases on on how we
would want to model this particular data
so just want to share with you um you
know being an early styler some a
blunder that we made as well so being a
nai machine and driven startup we care a
lot about our data and then how we store
them to optimize it for for data science
and machine learning and so on but even
with all the care and love you know with
us moving fast and then pushing features
we did and I'm actually messing up the
data at some of the earlier earlier time
so what happened was that we push the
food features that we stopped which we
set the character offset in the marking
where certain things are in the in the
text we store it a little bit off it was
just a taste based on different logic
well sometimes we mr. represent at the
time or the time zone is messed up
sometimes we forgot to set the proper
send a or we actually somehow set the
wrong one so an example is where some
record that have like just send a or
2026 which I'm pretty sure we didn't go
to future in the sentence and then yeah
it's some time we just completely miss
we forgot to store some information when
we push some of the changes so so a big
big there's a one project that we end up
doing was that how do we go back and fix
some of this so we actually roll piece
of code that we guy who is sitting over
there kind of recalculate bunch of these
data like reset the offset chain kind of
reconstructed a time entity from other
contexts that we know well yeah we
construct the time zone and and then I
after all that we able to salvage most
of the data and then yes for for data
science making sure that is it's
accurate we did within a dumping the the
small portion day that we could not
Salvage but that's part of moving fast
you can always plan for everything but
more about recovering fast and figuring
out the best way to to move forward okay
so talk a lot about data it's hard to
not talk about machine learning and then
for us being us so I'll end the top with
a couple of slides on our architecture
for for data science or how we power
data science so the first piece is how
do we get data to our data scientists we
want to give them as close to live data
as possible as much as we love them we
don't want them to be mucking around
with our production data or change our
messing up my performance in the in the
production environment so so this is
what we came up with for this what we
have right now so inside of the virtual
private cloud one that's that's a
production data
master slave replicas set and then
because we go Mongo's backup service
which periodically dump some backups we
just restore them periodically in a into
a totally separate environment in a
totally separate virtual power cloud and
then just have that into the become the
death database so that the TerraCycle
do whatever they want in that database
they can completely delete the database
they can do whatever they want we can
always restore that and then we can
create another separate machine learning
or data science database where they
that's way they store sort of the
derived data so whenever we do a mom go
down update restore we don't wipe down
all the data that they that they create
it so this have been working pretty well
for us I think just enable us to be able
to work on or get the data side there's
some pretty close to real-time data
without really messing up anything or
taking any risks on the production
environment
now finally so how do we train our data
so this is this sliding this out could
be another 20 slides so powerful being
the high level so what month or two how
to change the model that we use in in
production for raw data when the first
thing we do is clean it and filter it
partially is actually to clean out and
reconstruct some of those bad data that
we talked about but then also making
sure all the data is in certain level
that we that important to us that had
all the right attributes and then we
augment it we a lot of the different
techniques that we use in the end the
back end leverage similar features and
leverage similar pipelines so we
centralized it right so we would do kind
of the POS tagging or the entity
recognitions or like construct the path
tree that are there kind of so that all
the data we thought all the features
that would be available to the parent
next next line in the pipeline without
every single data sizes have to
reconstruct their own tags and then
after that we transform it into the
seven features that we care about
you know it's feature that like engrams
or thinking about what is what do we say
that the customer before this again we
have in conversation and whatever we say
actually has an effect on how how did we
spawn so that set of features all get
created so that all the downstream
machine learning processes can take pick
and choose whatever data set they want
or whatever feature that they want to do
their own predictions so that's this
super high level on how we do all our
finger and of course one thing about the
transform piece is that back to the
sparse data we we do have to create a
sort of dense representation of the
spa's data set so that it's pretty much
a dictionary right
say hey if you do an Engram and say
let's meet at is say it's a three gram
that appear in this particular slot and
then but then all the other things is
zero so let's just no need to represent
zeros but then of course when we
actually do the sometime classifier and
other machine learning algorithms we
need to have to expand it back out into
showing all the zeros so that's where
the two vocab huh
combined with the the that the dense
spots metrics matrix and then opening
back up for the English in learning to
at your charter that's a that's us and
happy to take any questions
that's what's bad
do we have problem dealing in daylight
savings time yes we deal with it
laughing absolutely and the time zone is
one of those a time zone time daylight
savings time is like our best friend but
yes we do and it's just something do
something you just have to take it take
into account
use the assistant - yeah - like the
person
so you're asking so you're asking for
how do we how do we how the Amy knows
the the guests in the meeting if they
are working with another assistant
yes holiday I know your travel plan
right we we know some there's certain
knowledge should we we just you have to
tell us right ladies you have to tell us
but they are signal that we can key off
on for example that you know you might
mop on your calendar that you're
traveling you might use services like
trip it to to to tell us so there's
certain available but even then it might
not be as as clear-cut as it could be
right because you could be going to
South by Southwest yes you're traveling
where you're definitely taking meetings
right or are you traveling to your
conference or you really take phone
calls so some of those nuances is that
we will make some good guesses and then
what we make guesses will generally come
back to you and let you know that by
will what kind of assumptions we're
making but to be honest like that does
certainly not a data said that you you
can just completely know without
informing yep
I mentioned a few times like favorite
coffee shop or media to this conference
or whatever so there's a lot of metadata
that's about there so conference can
only that certain number of people or
coffee shops might not have Wi-Fi is
there a manual onboarding process to
learn those places pieces of data and
properties or is this something that
just it's over
so onboarding is something we think a
lot think about a lot it is I think it
is a big piece of what we will continue
to be working on partially because we
don't have an app so in a way that
everything is invisible so we actually
have to drive that onboarding and let
you know what is available what you
should be setting and so and so forth
but I do think that on onboarding it
will be quite different than when you're
so typical and boring in a way that we
wouldn't we would depend on our
knowledge right for example since we
have your calendar we could do things on
by analyzing your calendar before you
even use it at all that we can see
because we can get a pretty good guess
again on what you like where do you meet
and so on so far what's a typical start
date aside time in your in your day and
what do you end your day good guesses
right so we can come back to you and say
what this is what I got does that does
that doesn't jive with what you actually
think and so yeah it is it is a work in
progress for sure but yeah I think it is
very very important piece of our
technology good
English right now it does only worth
English yes it's certainly something we
once we solve meetings in English it's
it is certainly a big one of the big
next step we want to do is expanding
into other languages
so we I mentioned that the XP program
sometimes makes mistakes and I was
wondering so we certainly have a set of
quality control in place that review the
discrepancy order if we get complaints
we can go back and look at the different
instead of trying to play back on
exactly what happened and then from that
and adjust the training or actually
myself I have to build new features to
make sure that we have to capture some
of those use cases yes so so the the fix
will get stored so then it is since
machine learning once you've fixed the
underlying data when we train the model
mix in a way it change the on the
mistakes
I wonder can your machine Tachi a real
person I mean if someone has it's not a
new thing
how can he talk to you so it just to be
clear we only need again the experience
it's exactly like if you have an
assistant right so if I have an
assistant you don't have one you would
talk to my assistant which in this case
would be XIII so that's my long answer
saying that no you did not
you don't need both parties to have X
dot AI for this to work you you have a
natural language conversation with the
with the assistant or with the AI
someone who doesn't want to talk to I
think I think that's fair so first of
all you interns accuracy we certainly
that's something that we will be working
working toward and making sure that I
have that super hierarchies that we
talked about and so if everybody depends
on the case in certain cases we are
extremely extremely good getting because
100% on accuracy and some way of still
working on firmers depends on what case
it is and how complex things are in
terms of the etiquette of scheduling
meetings so there's a part of it is is
the training on you know is would you
have problem you know sending you know a
very high up person emails right or I
mean you won't write because you're used
to using that as a technology that does
how you communicate so I think the the
the personal assistant type having used
to carry weight in terms of like you
know I'm important now I have a purse
but now this is a piece of software it
is a Productivity tool that you're using
doesn't make light little bit easier for
for both the the higher up and you as
well so I mean it's partially it's up to
you as well you know I can definitely
see some might be put off by the by the
idea of the pocket on the system but
that's part of your own judgment as well
so for example that we being able to if
you if we have proposed a time to you
and say that hey can you meet next
Tuesday at 2 p.m. and you say next
Tuesday at 2 p.m. works or like just 2
p.m. works that is very very close to
100% yep good give us a bit more details
about for evaluation preference
evaluation metrics did you take any
other factors into account when signing
I mean accuracy is the main metrics that
we drive off of because partially we
again have the luxuries of not real time
so that so think something yes things I
turn around time becomes a little bit
less important to us which allow us to
apply more complex algorithms so besides
that you know it's about getting it
right so I not really besides accuracy
that's really the main thing yeah it's a
bunch back there
besides setting up meetings personal
assistant earth assistance to
so I can expand another sure one of the
easiest way to just look down the job
description of what a personal assistant
does and then you just go down the
bullets but do to be a to be frank also
it's just yeah coffee but you know
vegetable more like four coffees it's
more on we already get those requests
right now so you know you schedule and
coffee chat with that for me can you
just recommend which coffee shop I go to
or if you're booking a dinner for me
already your schedule and dinner for me
can you actually pick the restaurant too
so that type of very very natural way to
how do we extend the process the service
that actually add value to a customer
that again our goal is to take away all
these mundane boring tasks out of your
life and kind of give you back time
right so whatever that falls into those
area is there something that we're
interested in back there oh yeah
war machine learning everyone
yeah I mean again it depends on it
depicting the right tool for the tasks
right I would argue them the meeting
schedule it's not that procedural I
think that's a lot of random edge cases
rescheduling someone want to all send
today they don't want to be face to face
anymore they want to talk on the phone
instead because they couldn't it could
make it in the meeting so and so forth
but with that said yeah I think it's
very much depending on it is different
techniques if I we were recommending
coffee shop yeah well we'll build a
recommendation algorithm to to do that
so I have a question here so it's about
hey about a user of this software of the
same personal assistant do you define
that user of this software as they
executive of the like a company or do
you define user to be also the person
personal assistant a human assistant of
data
executive so the point is it could be a
Productivity tool for one assistant to
manage the meetings or other stuff for
multiple people so that there might be
of kind of interface for became a verb
that human to just get a visibility
about the schedule of different person
and how it looks like and so that he or
she could just better manage everything
just wondering if you have yeah I mean I
think that's a it's a decent extension
certainly we're not our current focus at
the wrong things that I solve our focus
we're gonna do one thing one thing
really really well
but yeah with that you know certainly I
mean there is just in a scale
perspective right there are less
assistant out there who we can help then
people who need meeting schedule but
this year is not it's a fair father
exception
so context this makes a huge problem for
though I think all NLP type application
I think we are solving it and they in a
what we think better way the partner
partially is its delimited limiting our
context right like we are not trying to
build a all-knowing all-seeing AI that
does everything for you and tell jokes
and give you the weather and everything
else we do meetings and send Ola when
you when you look at the meeting scope
it is a lot more limited which enable us
to kind of do things that we just talked
about in terms like having hierarchy and
accuracy and understanding the edge
cases and be able to respond to you
intelligently I think that a lot of
those in play against each other
so yes it's a challenge and I think we
are addressing it
so thing is less about the data storage
itself but more about the features that
we think I think we do leverage English
language specific features to make
prediction much better right so for
other languages we have to leverage
other features and other ways of how you
do speaking or your writing or the style
that you write in those languages so yes
we did so in a way we don't have to take
that into account per se today because
we have to pretty much we train the
model on whatever new language that we
have to tackle
if you were to make technology choices
at these points knowing what you know
what I change anything not really I
think I think we're I'm pretty happy
with a lot of choices that we made I
mean don't get me wrong we've we've had
a struggle to it's not like it just like
everything just smooth sailing but I
think generally fundamentally I think we
did pick a lot of the right tools that
that photos for the stage that we are in
I would say that maybe we we thought
about scaling almost little bit too
early actually another example I think
we put a hello balancer in front of one
of our web servers and they're like day
two of the company and then I wasn't
working because the low Balan is like I
don't see any traffic so there's not
some how about passing through any of
the data so we had to remove the little
balancer so again come for us are coming
from like a big data perspective
sometimes excu how we think about what
is important now versus i what is
required for scaling so maybe more less
about technology choices than more about
how we approach it in the beginning
like the one that you already like the
top trees that's a very interesting part
is to watch it differently so again look
back to the the scaling piece we we've
decided we want to write in the
beginning we want to write everything in
2 s 3 to s a sort of tertiary backup but
we're not looking back at it is that we
never end up using it because between
the the master/slave database that we
have and the backup servers that we have
we have to have really good so there's a
disaster recovery for for the stage over
in so we actually end up to stopping
that process of writing all the data to
s3 because we're never looking into it
so that's another piece that I didn't
need so they spent time building it and
I was trying to find so because we have
both Scala and EndNote or javascript in
the in the system I think we spent a
little more time in figuring out how we
would kind of let the two languages work
together better in a way that's really
how we access the database how do we
think about schemas and stuff like that
yeah so a thing is not a horrible start
but I think if you start to look into
languages and say especially but what
we're trying to build that we're trying
to fill anything that we're going to
build it's with high accuracy and and
losing at least right now translation is
still not awesome even though if you're
you go stay at the Arthur anyway you do
translation for so introducing that
amount of noise into what we're trying
to build I think it's a significant
challenge of building good product
although probably want to build easier
problem
but I I wouldn't I wouldn't think it's
that radio but for things it's not just
the language right it's also how do you
use them like where somebody an email
people it's not that writing proper
grammar like you say people use email
like their chat rooms or use but
sometimes they run a program so how do
you know that even though they almost
look like different languages just the
way you you misspell things is that
that's how you text and now you're
writing an email like this text so
that's type of usage I think it's also
quite different in other languages as
well other languages ticking - I take
all the shortcuts as an example so maybe
you're right and then that's if that's
the case amazing for us I'm super happy
we don't put our data sizes can do
something else but I I am less
optimistic that that
five love the top can you talk about the
output from the animated system for each
email and how it like if if someone
emails me and says like let's meet at
the coffee shop near your office like
maybe that would go in and say your
Starbucks they are storing the
incremental antic entities but you'll
point out like being able to understand
what is required to schedule a meeting
like is it okay to say let's meet at
Union Square or is it okay to meet a
specific address address or do we have
to be on the 9th floor very more so I
think some of those are product choices
that we we end up making unlike what is
good enough in resolving like for
example you have for time is it okay to
say this to p.m. or do you have to be
like 2 p.m. and what minutes and one
second time of course we won't write to
the hours where we resolved you or if
you give minutes we take the minutes but
we don't need them in insight for
example so I think those are more
product choices on how do we actually do
that on the X exactly how we'll do that
that's that's a lot much longer talk
and artificial intelligence how do you
weigh out of different groups of people
maybe not way but like how do you scale
like what's the size of your data
science team okay so I give you some
ratio houet I think it's fun so you know
nothing your typical engineering team or
tech technology team in in startups and
other companies you have a seven to one
ratio about seven engineers to one data
scientists our ratio is about one to one
I think that's one very different
structure than another teams for us 2/3
of the other teams are in technology so
they're either data science actually do
the math one-third of the data science
one-third of their engineers we right
now we don't have a dedicated
infrastructure engineer we are actually
hiring for one but love it when you know
you're interested know somebody who
would be interested in working on AI but
are currently our back-end engineers
also some of them SS sort of a dev off
person our infrastructure the person
which again bring it back to some of the
technology choices enable us to do that
because we don't like for example like
we love Cassandra but like I think it
takes a two-person team to manage the
Cassandra cluster which I don't have
thank you